lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
considerar otro punto de vista al pensar
en un rompecabezas que de hecho khan
academy está enfrentando en estos
momentos y quizá ustedes por su cuenta
puedan conocer un poco más de detalle el
valor presente pero en este vídeo
ustedes podrán contemplar cómo es que se
toman este tipo de decisiones en canal
academia estamos buscando mudarnos a una
nueva oficina hay una oficina muy bonita
que tiene una renta de dos mil dólares
al mes y está esta otra oficina no tan
bonitas y medio cutre cuya renta es de
mil dólares al mes
aquí estoy simplificando los números
para facilitar los cálculos matemáticos
hablé con un arquitecto y me dice que
nos costaría diez mil dólares
para poder arreglar esta oficina cutre
de manera que quede como la oficina
bonita en cualquiera de estos casos
nosotros estamos buscando realizar estas
oficinas por 24 meses o sea 2 años 24
meses y el arquitecto dice que nos
tomaría un mes arreglar la oficina cutre
el dueño de la oficina bonita nos dice
bueno va a ser una renta por dos años
puedes ocupar la inmediatamente
en la oficina frita comenté con el dueño
está idea de nosotros invertir dinero en
la reparación de esta oficina y el dueño
me dice que por cierto no es una de las
personas más fáciles de negociar que me
va a cobrar ese mes de renta que me
lleve a mí el arreglar su inmueble
la oficina feita así que deberíamos
tener un contrato de 25 meses para que
podamos ya una vez que esté reparado
tener nuestros dos años completos de
renta de esa oficina así que cuál de las
dos opciones deberíamos elegir les diré
que emocionalmente no quiero gastarse
diez mil dólares en arreglar el inmueble
de otra persona que cuando mi contrato
termine va a poder rentar esa oficina
mucho más caras pero veamos
racionalmente qué es lo que tiene
sentido una forma de pensar en esto es
ver cuál es la cantidad de renta
efectiva que estaremos pagando por esta
oficina afeitar durante estos 24 meses
aunque bueno si pensamos en todo el
contrato vamos a tener 25 meses los 24
meses que nos interesan más el mes de
reparación y pagaremos
dólares por mes serán 25 mil dólares más
10 mil dólares de reparación vamos a
escribirlo igual que en el anterior 10k
o 10.000 y en términos de la vida útil
por ejemplo en este otro caso cada mes
de renta es un mes útil cuantos meses
útiles tengo en este otro lado vamos a
tardar un mes en repararlo por lo que
tendremos 24 meses útiles si lo vemos de
esta manera sin meternos con el valor
presente o el valor actual vamos a hacer
un cálculo muy rápido informal tenemos
entonces 35 mil entre 24 24 meses
sacamos nuestra confiable calculadora
hacemos la operación
35000 entre 24 y nos quedan a 1.458
igual a aproximadamente mil 458 dólares
por mes
y aun cuando yo no quiera invertir en
esta oficina afeita ya que solo podrá
usar la dos años y después el dueño lo
podrá rentar mucho más cara esto aún
tiene mucho sentido ya que la diferencia
en la renta es bastante buena es poco
más de 500 dólares que me estaría yo
ahorrando en comparación de la nueva
oficina si yo arreglará la oficina feita